this is a production of Cornell
University and this is also my extra
owners to be here in Cornell I would
explain you later on in one slide why
please wait for it and I like to start
my presentation with contents online I
will go through short introduction which
is mainly be will be few slide about key
SS because I think not a lot although
you familiar with this company and one
slide about myself then I will go very
shortly because I think you all all of
you aware about the global trends in
agriculture changes them I will take the
specific example in our very strong
program breeding program in which in
Germany I will talk about modern
printing technology and I will give you
example of successful application for
all three crops I'm book started whiskey
SS we are quite old company 162 years
and the history started here in small
village named Magdeburg Magdeburg have
excellent soils this is a best soil and
the story was following one part of the
family both the sugar beet Factory and
second mentioned if we are start to make
sugar big business we need to start the
selection and selection was started
before Mendell describes a law I will
show you later on them was Concord and
news 39 date-y 1945 somebody know what
is the date 1945
exactly and because transfer sleeping
became on the Russian part and the
British bond was involved in company
they decide to take part of gym plus for
stoppage M plus to west part of Germany
and to have new start in 90 I will show
you a one slide in iambic I'm BIC is not
only the company's this is one of the
oldest grew very in generally it's about
900 years history because the name of
Anvik middle age was ein book and both
beer is very very familiar at least in
Europe
Sam is we have type of changes today is
one of leading company in plant breeding
and we are about 70 tons of old pipe
here where we are operated this is an
big orange everything which is our
breeding station and green where we make
the testing we have three now is for
business units I was twenty years here
in see Rose working with wheat rye and
barley we have sugar beet and potato
I make always a joke everything what is
growing underground business units and a
sugar beet is historical our home and we
have made and sold everything to pursue
research in development and to be very
clear for us research and development
also including breeding breeding our
main innovative research and development
but we are also supporting our breed
increased old new technology and later
on I will tell you exactly what I mean
our help what here here we are in an big
old facility you could see here is the
catabolized facility and we put it
always change our coke now-famous is our
key the blaze logo I already mentioned
to you I will give one slide about
myself mark already mentioned I did my
PhD in geology in Belarus then I moved
to Lebanon Institute plant genetics and
crop research in indicate this is quite
unique Institute because they keep after
reunification on Germany and this is
unique of Institute because this is one
of the strongest and one has the biggest
gene bank but also five different other
department including molecular biology
including plant breeding above us a
really unique place a lot of research
going say in Germany then my second
scientific home and I am really proud
John Innes we have very very healthy
competition mark always is Cornell
University and later on I show you
because I was is my Gael and Sam as my
mark already mentioned I was for 20
years the head of reading technology not
head reading head of reading technology
or t SS and I moved from me it goes to
globally
this is document I promise to show you
because if you look it's 1997 and this
is was invitation by Suzanne I think he
was assistant professor in this time for
my first seminar here that's mean for me
I have really Muslim 20 euro relation to
Cornell and this is a relation is very
very positive and I really proud to be
again here in your facility going very
shortly on the global trends and I
divided here on population growth and
food security climate change and after
local condition ends instability more
with less here I think all of you know
about this situation for me is in
general this is very important because
we expected to have the reduction of
agriculture area per capita about 0.2
hectare
this mean we need to produce not only
the best quality but also amount of
product we put say Fitzie grow involved
and what is around of us because the
difference between animals breeding and
plant breeding is very obvious we are
working on plant breeding always is
different in Burma and what you could
learn from this slide you see this we
have surprisely increasing of
participation by five 7% until 2100 but
the distribution is became very
different for example probably not all
of you a veces Europe and specifically
Germany have very horrible here this
year drought I never expected such kind
of drought as we have this year in
Germany and some farmers specifically on
Lysol in East part of Germany not sent
combined to harvest canola herbs because
the yield was just 30 percent of
expected yield and going to the next
factor which is a global warming again
here we expected to have increased 2.5
or 4.1 and what is will be mean for us
depending of the different region of the
wall and looking on that says one per
one sin
degree of global warming to mean to ship
off the zone of climatic from hundred to
500 kilometers pool Ford's wishes would
mean again for South of France more
droughts more water use efficiency
variety should be all potential good
situation for East Europe Russian
Siberia where is a potential for for the
and last one third one here is and I
think it's not only row but everywhere
in the world we need to loop on that and
this is produced the same amount at
least with less nitrogen less and only
the solution for us to keep biodiversity
I try to put here the factory wishes we
expect it to target as essentials and
from right side our response from
breeding point and you could look by
herself for example for temperature
areas of course Hitler runs and you will
found here is for example root system we
are looking now I have 20 years ago a
nice interaction with breeder one of the
famous our body breeders and he
mentioned I not cases came from Rousseau
from Leafs as photosynthesis I measure
as float and I measure the Leafs sorry
yield but now he came in back and
mentioned you was right we need now to
dissect we need to know this from
variety a I have 5% more yield because
it's a good root system and I know from
variety be I have 5% more yield because
nice photosynthesis because then I could
combine in more precise in Bay talking
about current breeding targets in
example of our German wheat breeding
program and here is in one slide a lot
of information but most important for
you the area of growth of 3.2 if I am
talking about vesti of Rob the biggest
wheat winter wheat and I am talking
about mainly about winter wheat
era is in France with 5 million all
Biderman is 3.2 and about 2 billion in
UK
this is make totally in West Europe
about 10 million over winter with 9 we
are talking about number of listed
variety because the difference between
United States and Europe for example we
need to have official registration
currently a farmers have say choice from
140 different varieties it's also not
easy choice if your farmers how it is
selected the best but what has happened
in 91 we have 61 in 1970 we have only 38
varieties them if you look here is quite
interesting 5 biggest variety have in
1970 about 80% of acreage now it's only
33 if you look the percentage of
certified seeds and this is important
for us as invest is 48 percent which is
mean only second farmers buy certify
seeds
some farmers pushing us and mentioned we
need to increase the you need to
increase the resistance and if I if we
ask are you buying certify seeds they
mentioned not every year then the next
how we could to create new innovation
without to heaven money because in some
East European country the situation is
completely different in form some
farmers have petitioned by lessons is
sufficient to buy the seeds once in your
professional life and this is also some
part of motivation probably for you
understanding why as a company thinking
about to have hybrid we do have a
hyperbolic to have potential to return
the money but it also could be a
political solution for example in a
neighbor country of Germany in Germany
stills of a 50% white neighbor country
Denmark have about 62% of because
farmers believe there's good quality of
this is this is at one look on this
graph and this is nice hair for
discussion because some people mentioned
we have fully stagnation of the yield
this is the graph show in 1980 till 2008
it's not good as a yields this year will
be somewhere here because extremely and
almost no but if you look on the graph
is increasing of the we are talking
about the yield about seven to eight ton
of and this is industrial way of
producing of it in Europe but if you
look on the map of the Germany I'm from
lost our Sony another our capital is
Berlin you will recognize is over a
shield is here showing on different
countryside you will found some of the
ambitious very high about nineteen but
you will have eight and you will hear
here this is East most oil more light
soil again here is south and south heat
because hit by flowering and if I
talking about the heat is a different
house called interpretation from
different growing region because heat
here meaning the difference about 10
percent of the yield because during
flowering time here is much higher
temperature which is half negative
influence on the year and knowing that
we could increase now I move to very
basic breeding and I think most of you
very familiar visit because we need to
have two crucial point variation if you
don't have variation in one owes as a
way we could close our activity and then
selection and here genetic resources is
our basis in my couple of example of
excellent application I will show you is
a very positive example of using genetic
resources for improving quality or yield
of but be aware majority of the breeder
also not use genetic resources every
year because it's really hard to cross
from genetic resources to to achieve
them the same level of yield specificity
and quality and one in my example for
wheat I will show you what's the reason
here we have the crossing evaluation a
couple of years at least places
replication and if I am talking about
the place this is also very different I
already mentioned in in Europe we have
three program UK France and Germany for
example in UK we testing material in
only two location anyone know the reason
for and in Germany on 70 location
any idea why even in traumatic condition
in in in UK the major area of redrawing
is closely to Cambridge Norfolk and this
is ways our two testing locations
tension in location in Germany you have
seen the map and the conditioned
environment condition is very different
to be able to provide for official
testing and specifically for farmers
verify information we need to have more
location in continuum and them is
replication I think is with help of John
Luke and many other statisticians very
move three replication we are happy now
is to because the tools help us with
resistance yield and quality I will came
back to that official testing three
years in Germany two in Denmark and this
take again six to eight years and this
is eight to twelve years cost and
sometimes I mention this is like a
Russian roulette
you play gamble and you hope you have
the biggest right this is will be like
examination because this is a formula
you should know whole time if this is a
genetic game which is selection in
genetic standard if ignition engineer
generation to interpret very in simple
word to make the interpretation
intensivity bigger is better but you
know they because also costly if you
increase your program double you will be
half double possibility for success but
it will be double expensive you need to
accuracy is very good positive regulate
variance as well and also what
specifically I like to point it in this
case is interval time to be quicker you
are successful and this is not only rule
8 it is one breeding but also related
with as a type of industry but to relax
you a little bit I will explain here a
joke about the interval time because
board of some other company which is
mainly related with chemistry ask plant
breeder
with for example mark how long has taken
for you to develop the variety for
example if we double the budget for you
to make mm of the money would you able
to do it five year as this was exactly
the answer but in some chemistry if
you're a developer pharmacy you could do
that you put more money in beginning you
expect to have shot but this is plant
breeding and we are really proud because
our board still understood and understoo
in positive sense plant breeding and
this is really good to have looking on
that I give you a little bit about with
what we are targeted for and of course
you'll yield yield
but also quality or resistance agronomic
traits specifically yell stability
because farmers like to have not every
year as a high they like not only one
yield the highest yield
stable you and what we are looking also
nitrogen because you may know in you we
have special directive for application
reduction of nitrogen but if you compare
with breeding program is iceberg this is
only upper part of iceberg if you hope
good deeply this is what we are
selecting for and this is Mike
at least my opinion John Luke please
confirm is the difference between maize
breeding because in mainstream give us
always yield yield yield and yield now
it's became some disease important
nitrogen is important but looking on
wheat really future mount of trace value
and this is very very different
okay between different country later on
I show you why but before to give
because probably not all of you have
been inside already mark with breeding
program or at least Bali Pro I have here
couple of slides to give you to bring
you a little bit in the fuel side this
is a crossing this is a crossing some of
them very happy and I could omit I out I
also could cross wheat but I have my
difficulty to cross sugar bit because
this is really small
and next one you could see this as they
started this is probably you don't know
we use this is for cow elusive inter for
the age because the age is still quite
expensive but this is a really really
powerful tool very and then they started
selection you will see small plots as
breeders some breeders used only couple
of second to go to make say is this
election a long road and some disease
and you know the rules breeder will be
unhappy if it is no disease on the
breeders side because this gives
possibility for selection and secondly
sometimes I'm sorry mark in
misunderstand interpret as a job of the
breed success of breeder meaning such
job of the breeders to remove 90% of the
material from one generation to the
other deviation but what's the
difference between successful breeder
and unsuccessful successful breathe'
remove keep hand presence best
unsuccessful generator removes the
templates and
part of them and this is most important
for us because here we'll be combined
and combined will be measure everything
but you make mistake or not make because
here side-by-side comparison of the you
and I mentioned in Germany we have 17
location to test a yield because the
condition is I think is this life will
be interesting for you because look on a
farmer's field and this is one hectare
here is also one hectare farmer's field
farmers use about 8 hours for wheat
field for breeding field we used 600
working hours
let's make big difference I mentioned
that I would explain you a little bit
about the os3 program in Europe and here
we are in Germany here is our UK program
based in Cambridge of three positive
amperage and here we are in France again
a German is 3.2 france 5.1 UK flows it
2-1
this relate but they not overlapping we
could not make breeding from UK for
Fujian money we could make partly and
you see here overlapping for North of
German because the condition and target
is a new cable to have very short plant
type HT one example yellow frost or a
while so in Windows in UK we could so in
December shortly before Christmas winter
with still and in Germany we could do
not that but in Germany we need to have
at least a little bit winter Hodder's
and for France is extremely important to
have PBS quality and I would explain you
in next one because against the country
you have seen before in UK I think some
of you know the quality of the bread I
would not have commented it in Germany
we have different type of bread and in
France you should have at least baguette
quality as a case you're pissed
successful variety will be not work you
need so have say quality in France and
you see the different for exampie P is
25 EPS bread 69% in UK divided through
this width type and mix type of type
here is a you see the majority is going
to fit type in Germany a is export which
is a highest level of protein about 8%
the most famously 49 plots and here is a
quality this mean all breeders like to
fit the best variety in a because as
give mother breeding technologic I
already mentioned to you that his
company started here k SS foundation
this is was crossbreeding and them con
breeding is breeding hybrid breed sorted
here later on we have the same on rye
hybrid breeding can be a really proud of
that and I specifically show you a
little bit in Highbury Highbury so in
tissue culture here is molecular marker
area I think Susan you was pioneer on
rice first map I was pioneer honor first
ecology earlier I map and this is was 30
years ago the hope this is molecular
marker we will help we make the help
really and we still have big potential
smart breeding you could
on different way genomic research and
here also genomic slave and cannot type
in genome editing I will be put it also
somewhere here and here is stills
equation what will be the next and I
will be really happy to have from you
specifically from the younger generation
what PBS and our next step on one
breeding but going here tabloid cell
culture and we are really really happy
and we are happy on two different level
for example is this is not a secret
all our ballet program and not only all
majority of breeders operated based on
micro sport culture because it's very
easy is really efficient methodologies
from micro sport culture to make not
expensive - and this is make easy for
selection
unfortunately microspore culture till
now not perfectly walking on a weed is
still very high independence but we are
very lucky to use unser culture for
example if good potential
but both micro sport culture and and the
culture doesn't before I at all I mean I
have couple of ideas this relative is
open pollinated bees let out gene behind
of because homozygote e4i properties
this is a kill but this is a hippo test
we need them is marker-assisted
selection I already mentioned as this is
not bout that marker is helped us a lot
or specifically for targeted of very
important genes or allegory and genomic
selection I don't need to go in any
details here because I think you are one
of the pioneer for application and I'm
really very simple for you mark specific
page and look for you specifically to
help us to create idea to help us with
implementation I specifically put here
the slide is new breeding technology
meaning genetic and you I not use bit
specifically I put sunflower here I like
as picture and secondly you read here
the possibility to a gray eight
alternative a linear variation for sale
and this was big hope for us in
worldwide but also in Europe but what
happened
he is staying for high-level European
Court and the problem what is all this
old decision was was made not only Chris
Barker's gene adding technology consider
remain delayed but also all new
classical made method of creating
inducible mutation should be regulated
only exception was done exception
meaning here all product which is
already exist should be not because this
is could be put on the danger our shelf
in this is a mark of the half-empty
because a lot of mutation breeding
radiation mutation was done in the early
60 and Bali for example our traditional
German beer probably would be not
produce because it's variety was mutated
anyway this is decision is we need to
accept it this decision because this is
highest level of the court we need to
think what the solution could be what
the other possibility I would give you a
very short very quick now a few example
successful and very shortly for comment
for these slides this is very important
to have these pillows in plus efficiency
through genomic selection or the morgue
method of optimization your breeding
program and you should have the great
elements I would not mention only trace
SS sources of GM or gene editing also
for us and I give the examples roots
very important to understood what is
behind of of black books and enabling
technology because I think technology is
also moving process I will not go in
detail to comment what we have here you
may look here I'm talking about
precision farming by talking about
biologicals it just may have attention
and we looking for because again the
directive of Europe European Union to
reduce the pesticide which is positive
for environment but we need to have the
alternative latest decision was to take
neonics
which
see statement elements push are really
agriculture in Europe on the page
because the disease virus this is
extremely dangerous on different field
with Phil's our own very shortly in
Germany we don't have every year as
epidemics but what we observe every year
we have contamination this because and
this is problem from early walk of a
Hermann Buhl smile we know this is to
QTL and I'm talking now about for my
history this is already - line and you
could see this elite line from right
side here is already took two round of
the crossing but still is too long and
it's not only too long but is also have
a lot of acid is only the beauty here is
Fusarium resistance and this is what i
mentioned if you start to walk with
genetic resources potentially we have in
many cases many example linkage but
because we have now nice tool we have a
lot of market is not limitation now
anymore and we could potentially think
about to increase the recombination this
is give us possibility because one my
famous example I spot resistance on with
mark I think you started as your PhD
properly or before PhD is 30 years on
plant breeding to remove negative
linkage trick on the segment on
chromosome 7 because segment came from
aegilops wintry cosas and this took
extremely a long time to remove what
happened in our case I already mentioned
here to measure PDL and our idea was 15
years ago
I tried to put a ball speed rail in very
susceptible background opals and
moderate and what you could see here in
both case they put in here this balls UT
all these balls is one also and without
video we could reduce the FH parenting
but what was most important for us they
also could reduce very strong the
don't content
and we have a nice marker for said you
could really easily follow in the
program if some is took us at least four
years because we go from some is three
through spring queen width which is
quickest idle as winter weed because you
don't need internalization and we have
some prototype the reason why I tell in
prototype we still not release variety
the reason is because we still could not
fully combine the highest yield with
resistance we don't know it's probably
some biological mechanism behind it some
of you have been two years ago in Wien
in Austria on with genetics symposium
our last because next we will have
Congress and you maybe remember the
section of FHP was six presentation we
are now talking about very small
segments from some is three all six
present-day presenters mentioned my gene
is correct and a gene was described
before is not wrong we don't know what
is this this segment is potentially some
interaction we believe don't be some
interaction behind it we don't know hey
if we don't know mechanism and if you
don't know how the relation of
resistance with yield because in some
case and breeders who is very
experienced not going for hundred
percent of resistance to one leaf
disease because they mentioned very
simple if I make the leaf survey empty
from one disease another will and some
of them cost energy for plant going back
and this is a really nice example where
we mentioned for German government if
you like to do such project the country
we will do is Canada and this is show
for us is excellently how the
international cooperation to be
invincible moving to hybrid I which is
my famous subject I am real like because
I came from
cantabile Russia and rye breads a very
popular it's very healthy like Germany
used Poland used and this is very good
product look in here this is pre basics
is but look on that and to pay your
attention this is not like corn because
in corn you have to line we have a
little bit complex system
and please pay your attention here
because this is exactly the seeds we are
selling for the farmers and here is
importance as we have fully Poland
fertility restoration because if not
anyone have idea what will happen I saw
you here but probably most of you not
familiar bees air but but in early sixty
pharmacy specifically collected air good
because a mark could you help me was
they all follow it inside an import
important here as their pharmacy
collected because it was used in early
60 against abortion and you could assume
what will be if you have too much in
bread air good and occasionally and this
was case exactly where I really like
transplant see I like Brunei Walker in
Germany and this is biggest exhibition
of agriculture product and specifically
a real light go through organic and two
years ago the lady doesn't matter who
just promote the rye bread and mentions
this is most healthy bread you have ever
my next patient was a immediately what
what varieties and she mentioned me name
of all variety and they immediately next
patient what is this motor corn or
herbal and this is transference it
doesn't matter GM or organic we should
have clear description you should be
transparent enough to mention also some
organic product could be danger if you
have too much don't in your beat organic
production it is not healthy for you you
should avoid and here is a really
excellent example because variation on
the resistance is very very small we
don't have very small variation but what
is good is biological competition soon
we have enough healthy pollen grain
fungal doesn't have too much shuns and
this is competitions this is escape
readers will dimensions this is escape
but breeders professional breeder use
escape many many many times they
sometimes not care this is one was as a
type of
we know the position already a long time
and what is also beauty because we put
easily and I really like to show skill
all style style on marking to
differentiate between your tile tile in
sterile because as the case bleeder
should make next cross and next year
will found this is felt allows therapy
safe one here and of course as this is
segment here located on promise on this
and again this is line I will it and
this is sources we use very efficiency
by crossing system because to select
correct plant you will be a next
generation again you save one here and a
summary here this is was hybrid twenty
years before and now with our current
hybrid because this is Poland plus and
Poland plus is nothing else as use of
genetic resources molecular breeding a
smart breeding which is my opinion one
of the best example in Europe how we
manage it and came in a little bit to
the history I already mentioned I I
started with mapping coverage genome and
here is Professor Rick Eva's his five
six was five host rhyming and this is
chromosome two two markers some
microsatellite is some traits and them
reference you know we started is
cooperation I will show the pink we
improvement this year we will have
golden standard of right and what has
happened now we have 135,000 but we
operate it is six six times they did not
have any limitation but you may ask why
we need this all stuff if you don't as
one example like it if you because I was
also involved the double one is array
she 12 in weed is not intensive a
sensitive is is sensitive not
incidentally and located on chromosome
five you know already location but now
have all markers in four days we could
came to candidate gene and this is
peopled a perfect tool we could applied
for said to verify our old story
probably wishes help us now tool and
enforce it
and again this is not jobs one person we
are really happy this is this project we
have folk work as a pistol in fun in
technical university professor Geiger
who is a pioneer of hybrid with a hybrid
program right breeder 35 year on
breeding but we are really proud to have
a lot of young people who is with us who
learn about and who could bring this
knowledge to the next poly
I put not omit to stay without body and
here is completely different example
some of you maybe know Richard Pickering
he was all his life in New Zealand and
he woke on integration of segments from
her dimple bosom which is secondary pool
of ballet to heard uncle Gary which is
Bali which is growing on the field and I
am personally shoot on me I make mistake
I mentioned for him Richard nobody will
use this but we are very lucky that he
did because here is integration in one
chromosome is wishes give full dominant
resistance to bali trough wires and this
is a really important disease because
look on that this is with resistance
this is without you don't have healed at
all and this is transmitted through
unfit and because climate change we have
really big danger and specifically
because european union stopped
application on in 65 since i got very
weak because again and i'm really proud
and this is again related to the formula
you remember again generation interval
we start it immediately you publish
their your paper and we start it on
valley the reason is because and what we
did and this is all european material on
six-row barley it was happiness to see
if this means we mix of f different you
don't have clustering because breeders
and I'm talking now
not about hybrids I'm talking about self
pollinated crops this mean breeder
privilege
- immediately some variety release to
exchange material is very variable we
have read a little bit about now current
situation partly related is Nagoya but
also partly related here give us
excellent basis to stop genomic
selection and we need this wind molt is
basis for winter mold quality ballet
wishes became popular here and very very
simple race and I believe this is not
problem to selection but is problem for
selection because it's related to
singular anyway makes the story short
going through its important visual knows
that we will not replace the fuel
capacity but we put in fuel as the best
material it will also reduce genetic
gain per year to increase genetic ain't
very you because we reduce the cycle
theoretically and I already mentioned
PRP will take his dream to have half
your selection side is still far away
from what we have potential and we did
the same for molting poly because we
decide is okay
yield is important but important those
molding we published this in theoretical
to Oktoberfest which is in September
in not because it's genomic selection
this is very well correlated with
selection [ __ ] again very important
because you know and probably don't know
the assessment of molting qualities very
expensive and patient always if you go
to to to narrow and if you compare
compare the malting barley with fitting
poly you will see like white and black
very less genetic variation in Multan
public because all molting bali breeder
going for the quality you need to have
the quality but then you don't have
place for for for increasing of the
yield and we are really this was not
possible for us to do all this advantage
physical genetic map and we are really
proud and be self new round and don't
have time to put new science publication
on with but my personal opinion is nice
to have chance print as reference genome
and I'm really proud as we also involved
in 10 plus genome indeed because I think
as
happened already in maze we shoot to
have at least few variety and some of
them should go in quick truth is also
helped us a lot the technology developed
using cast in single application be used
in array still in-house application
again everything is related to genetic
what happened during class twenty years
you could look by yourself here through
genetics become become genomics be
informatique data integration by met
exchanges i enormous precision
phenotyping is limited factor and what
is most important for me personally and
for us translation of genomic knowledge
in breeders knowledge is essential
keywords about hybrid and to be aware
what we are looking we are looking not
mid parent hitter roses you will found
some publication 25% not belief onset
because you need to contract from
control heterosis meaning the difference
between your hybrid and the best elite
variety and this is not too much I was
really proud to be with literal English
to publish very nice review and
papier-mache but I put put it
specifically as aim for hybrid we are
still far away from I would don't have
probably time to go more deeply in
phenotyping we do on different level we
do on level of research we don't level
of reading and we do on level of the
field this is I already mentioned for
you very very crucial we are looking for
the solution we have some halfway we are
working also in plant physiology because
it still big disagreement some and
physiology publishing verify module not
an mentioned only experiment we could do
on control condition is experiment we
have completely different opinion within
our experiment is the fuel as a question
how to combine the looking and you know
state green is important for many probes
eros also
you're looking for mobilization this is
very important for me to show you
because public-private partnership is a
crucial and I think in Germany we have
very good example maybe we found a very
good solution because you know for
scientists is publication is must if we
will protect it is the company
publication we have problem to
cooperation but also he brings the best
material we bring our facility for
example this is very important slide for
me because I mentioned not only turnover
in company notice the amount of money we
for us is very important to keep the
next generation and we are really proud
own own plan but it's academies this is
a small but they keep it unique
opportunity for young tells if somebody
who have specification for I will really
open to discuss with you and give you
some advice on our but also not forget
about our issues my professor in
genetics in academic hotel OVA she is
now 90 she is still active on V and for
me this is a she is also part of
encyclopedia of Moshe Feldman she and
this is really if you have specific
vision some of you may be no union any
of he was in Pioneer here and professor
Geiger I know a lot of about population
genetics my gail he was the head and I'm
really proud mark to pull you up because
you also motivate me in some directions
genomic selection and finish my
presentation I like to give this you put
your a little attention to look through
and to look what is very famous and be
saw stay and this is the basis of gm+
for Canada Forest image and plant
breeding is not only science but also
its large extent of art of success and
not contribute without this variation
creativity and love us and this is my
message to you please try to spend your
time to think what's the kind of job you
like where's the job you go make your
happy this is not easy but this is very
important in our life and visit I like
to finish and I very simple for your
attention and I'm open for questions
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very interesting presentation
do you have a few minutes questions I
also would say people have specific
questions and we're finished here
that meeting 4060 plazas meeting and
kill for and I by anybody that wants
more with Victor come over here in
Aikido for attendance so our questions
kws went through life cycle is kind of
shut it down or didn't survive just fine
we simple yeah they were operating by
singles yes okay w wash down or how do
they I mean very complex question for me
we could okay after because I'm I came
from country wishes was very heartily
affected by listen code and I have there
also a possibility in epic a wishes for
Madera Institute to read listen co paper
in original in the Russian language I
mean we don't have too much affected of
key SS by listen caller this is a short
answer but now we came in back with
epigenetics and again what I could call
film not everything what he did and what
he write was wrong
and this is again message we talk with
young students sometimes we are too
conservative in our decision and
scientists mentions this is only white
and black but between white and black a
lot of different and this should be
ready also for compromise to think
probably indifferently
no company was not affected by listen
code
so right now a lot of us from these are
best resources to digital and if if the
decision to regulate you when we use
this precedent or maybe that happening
14 editing here on Troost you know how
did I mean you know maybe in a lot of
ways in the u.s. lucky because you
hadn't made this incredible financial
investment in this technology
right and we say okay cool we keep this
new one but what would be your new
feature advice to somebody who is
looking at Englishness technology with
the fear that in say 10 20 years
somebody might make the decision that no
actually we're going regulate I put my
note because i doesn't like because a
lot of things plays a role players are
Lords a politician and many other things
but as equation we answer will be please
invest in the technology but invest not
only in one technology I could answer
also from site of pharmacy in pharmacy
if it is from hundred projects you have
one successful you are successful and
last point to that but if you might
decision to invite or invest in hybrid
or in genome editing invest this is a
long term because in two years you could
not turn the game this should take four
hybrid with 10 15 20 years probably we
will be not successful I am quite
skeptic but it is my personal opinion
because I probably well inform on
direction of that but I also see the
potential because new advantage shown in
generic solution could be helped us we
will see I'm positive
one last question how long did it take
kws to commercialize their first hybrid
driver as the story was following since
the hybrid program was development by
Professor tiger in professorship and
they found the sterility and this is who
is the problem was with the restoration
team and soon they have already few
prototype of hybrid right they give it
this is product to two company key SS
and our competitors grade a specific
company for hybrid and both company
start because healthy competition is
also mortal it's very important and to
to register the first variety is still
but now we are this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu